Wow
good evening ladies and gentlemen I have
to introduce myself again for television
since we've just gone live on c-span I'm
John Fogerty Washington correspondent
the San Francisco Chronicle and I'm
president of National Press Club quiet
all right if you all be quiet you'll be
able to hear me that's the chuckman at
approach the quieting that an audience
it's one of the few things truck did
this year that work again I'm John
Fogerty I'm president of Club I'd like
to welcome you all be here at night to
our newly renovated facility it's really
just amazing what you can do if you work
really hard on nights and weekends now
my term expires January 18th that's 43
days 18 hours and 28 minutes from now
now I can't say that I've enjoyed every
minute of this term but I really have
enjoyed most of it I can't think of any
other posts that you get in this town or
any place else where you can meet the
president cabinet officers kings queens
prime ministers ambassadors the movers
and shakers and politics and business
radicals dissidents and Dear Abby all in
one year what's you it's a unique
institution a unique position I feel
very happy to have had the opportunity
to be the 77th president of the club and
this dinner is one of those reasons it's
really a very special moment for for a
president of the Press Club once again
tonight history's being made in the
Press Club ballroom this rooms played
host to presidents prime ministers
potentates for half a century was only
about a decade ago that the club thought
to honor the distinguished professionals
among us those who have made us proud to
be journalists tonight's honoree Helen
Thomas is the 1984 winner of the club's
most coveted prize the Fourth Estate
award
ladies and gentlemen
let me do what you all have already
started to do a toast to Helen Thomas
they say that people make the party and
it's pretty clear that the audience is
going to roll this one could I put Helen
is the first woman and the first wire
service reporter to win the award
and let me say to you that as I said to
the awards committee when we met one
time that the prize was overdue in both
categories
now past recipients of this award are
listed in your program and I will not
read all the names you can read them for
yourselves but we do have three here
tonight with us and I would now like to
introduce them and ask them to stand her
block herbert block her block of the
washington post
richard strauss of the Christian Science
Monitor of course TRB
and Simeon Booker Washington bureau
chief of Johnson publications and Simeon
now as you are all aware we have an
overflow crowd we I apologize that it
took a little longer to serve you all
dinner than it would have if we'd held
the crowd down but we wanted to
accommodate all of Helens friends
colleagues and as a matter of fact we
eliminated the head table so we could
squeeze in for more tails now you're
going to be hearing from a number of
friends of Helens
and I'd like to
what an entrance Donaldson you just
killed one of my lines and that was that
Sam Donaldson was stuck in the Atlanta
Airport but we all know about that now
you'll be hearing from some of Helens
friends and colleagues I would like to
introduce for people who are at our
knothead table but round table that do
not have to speak for their dinner
tonight first I would like to introduce
mr. Wharton Phillips who is the
gentleman who gives Dear Abby her advice
he's her husband
next is Jan Donelson wife of an ABC News
White House correspondent that you will
meet later Laura speaks wife of the
principal deputy White House press
secretary and my wife Jenny Fogarty in
this business we have a term called a
stopper that's a person that holds it
all together when when it's all hitting
the fan jenny is the stopper in our
household I would also like to recognize
Al Cromley of the Daily Oklahoman who
has for two years been the chairman of
the committee that chooses the Fourth
Estate Award winner it's a very
difficult job and I want to unaware he's
out here somewhere
I'd like to introduce jos Levin who's
president of national press foundation
which underwrites the prize Joe where
are you over there two other people that
really put this evening together
Don Larabee and Mary Beth Larabee
to other people I really want to
recognize are two people that known for
a long time and over the years I've come
to associate the word courage with both
of them that's Jim and Sarah Brady
now traditionally we ask three or four
colleagues and Friends of the honoree to
give an objective look at the real
person who are saluting more or less to
underscore our wisdom and making this
selection first I'm going to call an
Abigail Van Buren who's Dear Abby column
is the most widely syndicated column in
the world I might add as I learned
tonight that the San Francisco Chronicle
had the good sense to be the first paper
to run that column you wonder why it's a
successful newspaper her syndicate says
that there's an estimated 80 million
people read her advice and some 1000
newspapers everyday Abby must have some
important advice for Helen because she
came all the way from the west coast to
be with us and we welcome her to the
podium now
well Dave dear came over to my table
tonight and he said Abby I called your
syndicate and told them that Helen
Thomas was going to be given the Fourth
Estate award and she'd like to have Dear
Abby come say a few words
no money no expenses she can only talk
for three minutes they said you'll never
get her well they called give me the fax
and I said for Helen Thomas I'll pay to
go
if that could you say about Helen Thomas
I have known Helen for a long long time
she has covered five presidents and I
can tell you she's never met a president
she really liked
Helen's a real professional she never
takes anything for granted she checks
out all the facts you might say that she
is the original doubting Thomas now
Helens colleagues agrees that regardless
of her personal feelings and she has
them her reporting is always objectives
fair and with all the trace of bias but
those who know her well know where she
stands politically last year that a
crowded gridiron cocktail party someone
asked me if I'd seen Helens pal Fran Lua
I said well she's right over there
just left of the Helen Thomas stranger
behind me said nobody is left of Helen
Thomas
no this has not been verified but Helen
was credited with the following I have
good news and bad news first the good
news a busload of anti er a people just
went over a cliff now the bad news three
seats were empty
sorry Ellen true helen is revered by her
colleagues I was told that when Joe
Leighton was a deputy press secretary
thank you mrs. Layton
joe said that his his bedside telephone
rang at four o'clock in the morning well
he answered it is somebody from UPI I
asked a kind of a dumb routine question
and Joe snapped for Christ's sakes Helen
Thomas could have answered that the
person on the other end said yeah I know
but we wouldn't dare to disturb miss
Thomas at this hour now here are some
facts about Helen
she is scrupulously honest she has never
been known to betray a confidence
she loves to laugh and she enjoys a good
cry she loves to cook but she hates
housework she loves to eat but she hates
the exercise she is fiercely loyal to
her friends she's proud of her heritage
she's a honey helen is a champion for
women's rights civil rights human rights
she hates poverty bigotry deceit and
injustice
now I promised Helen that I would read
her favorite Dear Abby letter and I will
every Dear Abby to women just moved
across the hall for me one is a
middle-aged gym teacher and the other is
a social worker in her late 20s these
two ladies go everywhere together I've
never seen a man go into their apartment
or come up do you think they could be
Lebanese
well I'm not Lebanese God knows I'm no
lesbians but I want to tell you I just
love Helen Thomas
Larry I don't envy you
I'm we I'm glad I get to open and close
this program and stay out of the way and
the bigot in the myth in the middle
we've been we've been waiting
Don Larabee says he's been waiting four
years for someone in broadcasting
maybe Sam to say Larry spokes the white
house speaks Minh and I would now like
to bring up Larry
well a roast of Helen Thomas I have been
waiting four long years for this bubble
but I can't be too tough I'm the only
one in this crowd that's got her face
her tomorrow across the briefing room
they told me to say something funny
about Helen Thomas for a guy that faces
her every day they ain't nothing funny
about Helen Thomas but a bit from back
stairs at the White House you know they
say Helen Thomas is getting soft on the
president she's becoming a patsy in the
White House
well I'm here tonight to defend Helen
Thomas and say it just isn't so you know
she's the only reporter that writes what
the president meant to say before he
says it let's look at some recent Helen
Thomas stories Dateline
Geneva by Helen Thomas United Press
International White House reporter
diplomatic sources today said President
Reagan will hold a summit meeting with
his son Michael
the White House the White House denied
it our statement was our position
remains the same we must have a well and
well developed agenda and a reasonable
chance for success Helen wrote that I'm
just reading it another singer on the
president's foreign policy Dateline
Moscow highly placed diplomatic sources
revealed a letter President Reagan wrote
to Soviet leader Chernenko quote you and
I have much in common the president
wrote I can sympathize with your
problems you have troops bogged down in
Afghanistan unruly priests preaching
freedom in Poland and a lousy wheat crop
in the Ukraine and the president wrote
I've got Helen Thomas asking me
questions at my press conference system
did he really say that
and she writes about the budget and does
she write about the budget Dateline
Washington the White House today
revealed a major Bludd budget cutting
decision the new Reagan budget will
distribute the burden of the deficit
reduction equally on the rich and the
poor alike both are entitled to the same
amount of ice only the poor will get
bears in the winter that's the only
difference another budget decision
Helen writes this one o new federalism
which is a joke in itself the federal
government will now provide the cheese
but the states have to buy their own
crackers
and you ain't seen nothing yet White
House aides today came up with a plan to
do away with the federal deficit once
and for all they said put it in a
suitcase check it on a Piedmont flight
to New York that way you'll never see it
again one more - our budget meeting and
I'm going to recommend that one date
line the Cabinet Room Reagan budget
cutters were added again today trying to
hammer out an agreement on defense
spending
Secretary of Defense Caspar Weinberger
was described by one participant as his
own worst enemy David Stockman stood up
and said not as long as I'm alive
I believe that one and then after the
president named his cabinet and sent him
to the Senate for confirmation Helen
wrote every one of the president's
nominees were subjected to ideological
sniping vicious innuendo anonymous slurs
and general character assassination and
that's just from the White House staff
Helen is it true that you have a key on
your typewriter that says Larry speak
said what the president meant to say was
but to set the foolishness aside and
some serious words about Helen Thomas
she's been honored for many things first
woman close to a president to close the
presidential news conference with the
traditional Thank You mr. president
first woman arms to the National Press
Club first woman officer of the White
House Correspondents Association first
woman member the Gridiron Club and
tonight she becomes the first woman to
receive the National Press Club fourth
estate award but she's being honored
tonight not because she's a woman
although that's important she's being
honored because she's a pro a true
professional in every sense of the word
a story comes to mind that really tells
what this reporter is all about that we
know so well and who knows her beat
better than anybody has ever known it it
takes place on a quiet Washington Sunday
morning not long after President Ford
took office in 1974 at 9:00 a.m. on that
morning calls went out all over
Washington come to the White House
immediately the president will make an
important announcement well the news men
recall raised questions what is this is
it foreign is it domestic what is it
well the White House wasn't talking big
secret the mystery prevailed as a pool
of reporters gathered to go in the Oval
Office President Ford was in the wings
awaiting his cue to come before the
cameras and Alan spoke
and scoop the world she said I've got it
he's going to pardon Richard Nixon and
she was right call it intuition call it
luck call it what you made but I call it
professionalism Helen your illustrious
predecessor
Helen's illustrious predecessor at the
White House the late Merriman Smith once
said in a moment of frustration where
have all the Giants gone little did he
realize he himself had become a giant in
this business we call news Helen you too
are giant respected revered yes and
loved I've got a letter that only comes
on this green stationery from one person
dear Helen I'm delighted to join your
colleagues and many friends and
congratulating you on being chosen to
receive the National Press Club fourth
estate award this award is a
well-deserved tribute to your
professionalism as a journalist you have
a worldwide reputation for being the
best always first always accurate always
fair millions of citizens are
enlightened through your work and you're
an inspiration to all who seek to be
good reporters hardly a day goes by when
I don't ask the staff what is helen
writing for your experience and wisdom
have become a barometer on the issues of
the day you're not only a fine and
respected professional you have become
an important part of the American
presidency I am proud to salute you
tonight
sincerely Ronald Reagan
let me let me say one more thing to
Helen and Helen you said it a thousand
times
Thank You mr. president well tonight let
me say it for all your colleagues all
your friends all your readers Thank You
Helen Thomas
while most of us tonight had to make it
through the elements from McLain or
Bethesda or someplace like that our next
speaker had to fight his way back from
San Antonio through the Atlanta Airport
and we really had almost given up on him
but but fortunately the everything
worked and he got here we're also very
fortunate to have him because he's known
as a rather shy retiring individual who
normally shied away from the public
spotlight and so we feel very pleased of
National Press Club that he has agreed
to speak tonight welcome Sam Donaldson
Ellen I do bring you greetings from
Frank Borman in the Greater Atlanta
Airport it was tough but I was coming
back from San Antonio where today I had
been denouncing Ronald Reagan's press
conference policies what press
conference policies before a group of
news directors and Jim and Larry
Helen would have wanted it that way I
want to say a few words have I known
Helen Thomas by knowing Helen Thomas
there was that windy day on the South
Lawn many years ago reporters were then
allowed in the South Lawn without
handcuffs on
they planted a tree a cedar of Lebanon
on the South Lawn the president was
there the ambassador from Lebanon many
dignitaries and when they were left we
reporters remained behind in those days
we were allowed to remain behind in the
South Lawn and we said to Helen here is
the shovel shovel in a little dirt then
she at first didn't want to do it and
finally we prevailed on her and as she
did it I felt the ghosts of presidents
past present and future saying shove her
in
but we did not and I think the reason
presidents feel that way one of the
reasons is that the questions she asks
them Helen do you recognize this
question mr. president now that your
policy in Lebanon has failed in the
blood of 261 Marines is on your hands
and you have battleships there for no
good purpose and you're allowing the
marauding Israelis to occupy the country
my question is this sir what's going on
here and I have two follow-ups
substitute Vietnam for Linda Johnson
substitute Watergate for Richard Nixon
the question is always the same it
drives them nuts as well it should now
but her questions are not always long
one time I remember the Ronald Reagan
came to the press room flanked by
senators from both parties he had been
hammering out he said in his office a
compromise on the MX and he said I'm
pleased to tell you that we have today
hammered out a compromise to save the MX
and I want to compliment both the
Democrats and the Republicans for
putting the country's interest and for
thinking of this great land of ours and
for saving the MX by agreeing to this
compromise of course it felled the Helen
to ask the right question mr. president
she said what is the compromise well
what is the compromise
what is the compromise John John tower
won't you tell him what the government
sad world John got up and he told him to
compromise you remember that day the
president retired and I gave him full
credit for hammering out that compromise
never mind he had not the foggiest idea
what it was that is the test of
leadership I'll agree but we have to
have Helen come Helen is always working
and she taught me a valuable lesson
early on when I first came to the White
House she is always working and that is
what a reporter should do one late
afternoon I wandered into the lower
press office the door was shut which was
unusual for those days today of course
the core is always shut and I discovered
their little party going on for a fellow
named Rex Grantham it was his birthday
and he occupied the corner office in the
lower press office and they had a little
champagne and cake and they didn't
really want me there but since I'd
wandered in to come on and have a little
champagne so I did and a few minutes
they shut the door a few minutes later
Edie Bradley who was in at the White
House wandered in same thing happens
come on in and have a little glass of
champagne and he did he shut the door
and here came Jimmy Carter now it was
clear why they had the door shut now I
had the door to the press room shut not
to the upper well anyway he came down
and he sipped a little champagne and Ed
and I who had covered his campaign began
to just reminisce with it but do you
remember that night in Milwaukee mr.
president was raining you know and you
said that silly thing and all that and
he was responding we were sipping
champagne and pretty soon the door open
and there was Helen she had discovered
the party she came right in she said
hello mr. president now about your
energy program what I want to know is
well he ran away of course but I learned
a valuable lesson that day and the
lesson is this if you're ever having a
little polite chat with the president
you see Helen Thomas coming shut the
door and lock it
now the lesson is that Helen taught me
as she's taught so many reporters before
me and reporters after me that the
purpose of being in the White House is
trying to find out what's going on there
which is a combination of what they say
is going on there what the critics
contend is going on there but over and
above that her own judgment built on
years of experience about what's going
on there that brings to Helens reporting
something at rest of us life and hell
I've got to say to you tonight I've
learned most of what I know there from
you you have to take the blame for that
but I'm going to move on presidents come
and presidents go and reporters like me
come and we go but Helen Thomas we need
you to stay forever and I hope you do
thank you
I think I was a wonderful speech for
Helen Sam and I think now that probably
Peter Jennings is wondering where are
you going to go that's Peters problem
our final speaker tonight is grant
Dillman who was perhaps worked with
Helen longer than anyone in Washington
as the Washington Manager of United
Press International he was her boss for
many years now he's executive director
of National Press Foundation which
provides support for the Fourth Estate
award and other awards programs grant
wants to tell you about the Helen Thomas
he knows
well this evening sort of underscores a
question that I've been harboring for a
long long time
good grief Helen Thomas is there no
escaping you this morning you were in my
bedroom talking about presidential
children on Good Morning America on the
subway I found you plastered all over
the Washington Times and then I sneak up
to the Press Club for a quiet drink and
here you are receiving the club's fourth
estate award
Helen after nearly 40 years of this kind
of thing isn't that enough more
seriously now that we've heard all of
these innuendos about Helen let's talk a
little bit about the real Helen Thomas
to use a word attributed to Ron Coan by
The Washington Times Helen has some
warts Oh Ron said she was unique but he
said she had some warts let me tell you
about a couple of them first she ignores
her bosses I can't tell you how many
times Helen has been told to cut down on
those 16 and 18 hour days but still
every morning she's there at the White
House before almost everybody of course
there's a good side to that somebody has
to find out what's going on until Larry
speaks
Helen also has problems with economics
she once told an interviewer she loves
her job so much that she would cover the
white house for nothing unfortunately
the new owners of UPI found out about it
and they decided what was good enough
for Helen was good enough for everybody
and they cut wages 25% Helen also
addresses a lot of groups including
publishers and the trouble is she
insists on telling them the truth about
the Reagan administration and we know
how some publishers feel about that kind
of truth in fact they sometimes complain
to Helens bosses but she refuses to
reform just a stubborn woman I guess
helen has another serious deficiency she
can get very angry about injustice but
she has no sense of outrage where her
own welfare is concerned at one point in
her career she was teamed up at the
White House with a man who felt strongly
he should be number one and who treated
her accordingly
Helen never complained even when it
became obvious he was out to undercut
her in every way he could she just
worked all the harder and beat him out
for the job on merit he went on to other
and lesser things
in short though I don't quite understand
why we're honoring this woman with all
these defects all she has brought to
journalism our dedications professional
skill tireless energy loyalty and a
fierce determination to inform the
American people on what their government
is doing but if you persist in this and
tell you by the response I guess you
will John Fogerty is here to do the
honors mr. president
ladies and gentlemen it's my honor to
make two presentations to Helen first
caricature that is on your programs of
Helen which I would like to present to
her Helen come when up I'm running out
of room a second
Helen on behalf not only of the National
Press Club the Board of Governors and
the National Press foundation but of all
of your colleagues in this town all of
your friends all over this country and
all over the world the Fourth Estate
it's a little hard to hear your obituary
when you think you're still alive
Sam we really wanted to provide the
helicopter motor roar while you were
speaking couldn't manage it good evening
mr. president
colleagues friends and relations I am
deeply honored to receive this award
from the National Press Club and deeply
grateful I'm also grateful to United
Press International which has allowed me
to cover a great Beach of infinite
variety frustration and fun and to my
colleagues and UPI who have always made
me look good
in the end I guess I owe it all to
presidents past and present
I've always felt greatly privileged to
cover the White House and to have that
proverbial ringside seat to instant
history irreverent as I may seem early
on I decided that presidents were human
too
I'm not sure when I reached that
conclusion some of them were all too
human with their Joy's their sorrows and
they're rare nobility presidents of
course are a study in contrasts each has
put his own stamp on the White House
each wants to go down in the pages of
history for greatness but greatness
calls for presidents to rise above
themselves and to rise to unforeseen
occasions and sometimes they have one
man with courage is a majority and often
one hopes that a president will be that
kind of person one thing I've learned in
my years at the White House and
particularly in the era of the Watergate
scandal all roads lead to Rome
the White House gives the orders sets
the tone and it's the president's
political philosophies that prevails
in the end it is the president who must
be above all incredible and accountable
I saw two presidents go down the drain
because they had lost their credibility
and they could no longer convince
persuade or govern Lyndon Johnson /
Vietnam and Richard Nixon in the
Watergate scandal I can assure you there
is no joy in the fall from grace of any
president on the other hand there is
some satisfaction in knowing that there
are safeguards against the abuse of
power and that no man not even a
president is above the law
as as for the press we defend the
people's right to know almost everything
for a nation ignorant and free never was
and never will be a democracy we know
that information is golden
it's the sink Winona of giving people
choices before they are faced with
effect accompli it is our role to see
that people are in on the takeoffs as
well as the landings from my view from
the bridge secrecy is more harmful to a
free society than almost any so-called
lead
all the presidents have fallen victim to
the syndrome of secrecy and they all
become apoplectic over disclosures that
often often legitimately belong in the
public domain dealing with our fate but
then they get over it
sometimes that is unless they resort to
lie detectors or the plumbers viewing
information as their private preserve on
the question of credibility the press
and press secretaries also must live up
to the high standards that they set for
presidents come to think of it I think
our credibility stacks up pretty well
against save presidents we
we in the press know that in the eyes of
many our role is dubious that we are
self self-appointed watchdogs of
democracy anointed by nun feared by some
and dieded we hope by one main ethical
goal to pursue the truth wherever it
leads us
we reporters are tested daily for our
devotion to accuracy and our profound
responsibility to the American people we
too are subject to a public judgement
our report card is on the front page
every day and when we fail we fail all
the importance of a free and robust
press cannot be underestimated clearly
no dictatorship can tolerate a free
press or survive under one as you can
see as you can see I don't waste my
sympathy on presidents particularly
since I think that they enjoy one of the
greatest honors that can be bestowed on
anyone and that is the trust of the
American people I'll go with Jeff Carter
the president's youngest son who walked
over to a group of reporters and
cameramen in Plains Georgia on a
Christmas Day as we were watching Carter
play on the front porch with his
grandchildren obviously playing for the
cameras don't you feel sorry for your
father the burdens the press always
watching Jeff was asked and he said no
he asked for it
and I'll go with Justice Brandeis who
said that a constant spotlight on public
officials lessens the possibility of
corruption every president has had his
troubles with the press gaining back to
George Washington in our press room at
the White House there's a photograph of
FDR with the inscription to reporters
from their devoted victim Truman said
when the press stops abusing me I'll
know I'm in the wrong Pew Kennedy said
I'm reading more and enjoying it less
what LBJ said is unprintable
and Carter Carter always seem to be
saying Lord forgive them for they know
not what they do as for Reagan well it's
like those silent movies he thinks that
we should be seen and not heard
and when the Sandinistas fired on press
helicopters near the Honduran border a
few months ago Reagan said there's some
good in everyone I think that Amy Carter
kind of summed up the attitude toward
the media when her mother has guarded
her to school in the first day of class
after the Carters had moved into the
White House and they want to show that
Amy was going to an integrated school
public school the press had been alerted
that they could record this great moment
in history and never harassed Amy again
walking down the path to the school door
holding her mother's hand
Amy looked at the reporters cameramen
flanking the walk and said mom do we
still have to be nice to them I have
many memories covering the White House
have been times to laugh times to cry
times to wonder I remember when we
covered John F Kennedy during the
transition days in 1960 at Georgetown
Hospital after his son John John was
born and we asked him if he would like
to his son to grow up to be President
and he said I just want him to be
healthy and I remember riding on Air
Force One when Kennedy came back and we
teasingly asked him what would happen if
the aircraft crashed I know one thing he
said your name will be just the footnote
and I remember Jackie coming aboard Air
Force one one day with her German
Shepherd new German Shepherd named
clipper that had been given to her by
her father-in-law Joe Kennedy and we
sent her a note Fran will remember this
question what do you feed clipper and
she wrote back answer a reporter's
and when we asked Kennedy how he had
become a Navy hero he said it was
absolutely involuntary they sank my boat
and I remember when Kennedy gave a
dinner for the Nobel Prize winners and
lifting his glass and a toast he said
never have so many intellectuals
gathered under one roof since Thomas
Jefferson dined alone and I remember
when scientist Linus Pauling also a
Nobel winner picketed the White House
one day with a ban the bomb sign went
back to his hotel changed it into a tux
and came back to the White House dinner
and I thought it was a shining moment in
democracy and I remember when Sarah
Vaughan sang at the White House and then
danced with Johnson and Hubert Humphrey
and later the black singer tearfully
told us twenty-five years ago I couldn't
sit down in a restaurant in this town or
when a rabbi spoke at the Martin Luther
King rally at the Lincoln Memorial and
he said that the greatest sin of all
during the Nazi era was silence and I
remember the frustration of LBJ during
the Vietnam War as more and more
supporters broke ranks and one day at a
White House reception Johnson beckoned
Senator Frank church over and he was
very critical of the war at the time and
he asked him just where do you get your
ideas from walter Lippmann Church
replied while said Johnson the next time
you need a dam in Idaho you just ask
Walter Lippman
that is
at his first press conference two weeks
after he was in office
Johnson was asked to cite his biggest
problem and he said being president once
as a guest that the LBJ branch with a
group of reporters when Johnson was vice
president he took us for a walk down a
country road one evening to visit his
cousin Oriole and we obviously had
wakened her and when she came patting
bear especially when she came patting
barefoot to the door and later I wrote
that what I thought was a warm
sentimental story about a wonderful
white-haired lady who lived in a
ramshackle house cousin Oriole was
furious and she sent word back through
Johnson does Helen Thomas sleep with her
shoes on
and I remember when Johnson was taken to
Bethesda Naval Hospital for gallbladder
surgery psychiatric ward had been
transformed into a press room what
happened what happened to the patients
Johnson asked bill moyers is then his
press secretary we gave them all press
cards said no and I remember at a dinner
at the LBJ Ranch when Johnson asked
Moyers a defrocked Baptist minister to
say grace
Moyer's benches head began to pray and
Johnson commanded speak up bill I wasn't
talking to you mr. president Johnson
used to impart a lot of wisdom to us he
used to tell us if anyone tells you I'm
just a country boy reach in your back
pocket and see if your wallet is still
there and then there were those by time
death marches around the South Lawn in
the days before women were liberated and
we all wore high heels and I remember
LBJ used to complain y'all have the
First Amendment as if it was some weapon
invented against presidents and come to
think of it it is I won one day on the
10th round Johnson said plaintively that
after when we're talking about the war
he said I've got all this power and I
haven't used half of it yet and that's
what I really wanted to run for cover
and one of his favorite stories was of a
lad who took an oral exam to become a
brakeman on the trains the boy was asked
what would you do if you saw two trains
approaching each other on the same track
at 70 miles an hour the boy said well
I'd go home and get my little brother
well why would you do that he had he was
asked because my little brother has
never seen a train wreck before
and I remember Mitch Costanza who said I
don't mind Carter being born again but
did he have to come back as himself
and I remember asking Billy Carter if he
had been born again and he said once is
enough
and I remember Miss Lillian the
president's mother who said sometimes
when I look at my children I wish I'd
remained a virgin I recall interviewing
miss Lillian in plains in 1976 and she
was still seizing over Frenchwoman
correspondent to it interviewed her a
few days earlier kept asking her about
Carter's promise never to lie
do you like she asked miss Lillian well
miss Gloria an acknowledged I'm I might
tell a little white lie well what do you
mean by a little white lie she was asked
finally in exasperation Miss Lauren said
do you remember when you came through
that door and I told you how beautiful
you look
and I remember Martha Mitchell who said
politics is a dirty business and who can
forget the president in those dire
moments in the hospital in 1981 and
looking at the bevy of nurses and
doctors hovering over him said if I had
gotten this much attention in Hollywood
I never would have left and in the world
of interesting people there was Henry
Kissinger man was a mammoth ego woman
ran up to Kissinger and said Oh dr.
Kissinger thank you for saving the world
he said you're welcome once once when
Kissinger teased Kissinger teased his
Secret Service agents that he might be
kidnapped
they told him don't worry we'll never
let them take you alive
we we in the press know that we are not
loved that we don't win popularity
contests and that the pendulum swings
with the times it was a story to be
understood maybe asking too much of a
public that wants to kill the messenger
brings the bad news but it behooves us
to let the chips fall where they may
and above all to be fair engraved in the
mantle in the State Dining Room at the
White House below a magnificent portrait
of Lincoln is a prayer by John Adams
which says may only good and wise men
live here and surely we all hope for
that and Lincoln said let the people
know the facts in the country will be
safe I believe that and I believe that
we should keep an eye on presidents who
have life-and-death power over all
humanity today to keep the people
informed and democracy alive thank you
ladies and gentlemen thank you very much
ladies and gentlemen thank you very much
Helen I hope that you will give us the
chance to get your text I would like to
arrange somewhere to have it reprinted
not for what you advice you gave for
presidents so much as for the advice you
gave to reporters I don't think that any
of us in this room intend to be
President but what you said about what
we need to do needs to be reviewed over
and over again by us thank you very much
thank you ladies and gentlemen
that was Brian Berger
please take inspector
you want to tell them that confession
yeah